[Music]
you're a very busy actor you're in the
business uh you have kids do they
understand
what it is you do i kind of because i
have kids and i almost prefer that they
didn't know
what i did and then sometimes they see
me on tv and i feel like it's weird do
your kids understand they think it's
strange that you're an actor yeah i
think they think i'm a bit of a clown
you know they uh
we uh we we we're on the mindy project
we're doing this we just did this
episode called the triathlon
and i was unfortunately written in a
speedo
right um i was taking over the swimming
portion of the triathlon so uh uh
stupidly i went outside of my house
my my wife took the kids out
and i i went out back and i got a a tan
but it was a sunburn right so so people
said you know what you could do you
could spray tan i don't know have you
ever gotten this yes i gotta spray ten
well like i for a bit on the show for
charity i said i'd get cornrows and a
spray tan and they i did it because we
raised money for charity but i got the
spray tan and it's unbelievably invasive
yes yes
incredibly invasive yes
uh my my wife was out for the night and
i had my my three-year-old and my
four-year-old to myself and this woman
comes to the house and i'm just meeting
for the first time and she she brings me
upstairs into my my bathroom
my kids are watching some cartoons or
whatnot and she takes out a tent uh or
that there's almost like a cage
and uh she says okay you just take off
all your clothes and i'll spray you down
you know
i said do you want me to cover my penis
or do you want to give it a sock or you
know what do you want me to do
and she's like no you know i've seen it
all i'm good if you're good i'm good so
i was like okay fine so you know you
stand you stand and it's like you're
completely naked and you don't okay
you're completely new
you know you know when you go through
the uh security in the airport i was
standing like this
and um
and my four-year-old walks and and she's
she says can you cup your balls can you
lift your balls all right you know i'm
sorry okay sorry
and so so i'm like this
i'm like this
please it's my birthday i'm sorry
and she uh and my four-year-old's saying
uh what are you doing by the way the
machine is very loud the tanning machine
so this is a traumatic experience for
your four-year-old you walk in you're
naked holding yourself and getting shot
in the groin with a laser you know
yeah that's that's crazy he said what
are you doing and i've i'm getting a
spray tan so i just try to explain it to
him he said can we get one
[Laughter]
no we can't get one so i i think my kids
think i'm a bit of a clown well it
sounds like you are you're not shy then
about nudity if you're willing to you
know
get that be that exposed for str you
know for a stranger i mean you've you've
done nude scenes in movies and things
like that so you're not self-conscious i
have yeah i have i i uh you know it's
i've done it in plays a lot and when
you're in a play you can you're
backstage and you could kind of
you could fluff a bit you know
you know what i mean
no i don't know what you mean
you can maybe uh what you're saying is
you can get yourself into a state where
you'll be more impressive exactly
exactly
uh
in in in the movies or at least that i
did this movie called 28 hotel rooms and
i was nude for
a a a large amount of the time and uh
and the takes went on for a really long
time so yeah you couldn't fluff and so
but then what happens is
the other day my wife she she was online
and she pointed out a picture
and she said look this is a picture of
you completely naked from 28 hotel rooms
and my penis was about this this big in
in
the picture so that's the problem you
you're forever on the internet with with
you know it was very cold you can't
explain anybody
very cold that you might want to say
that first before you get to that part
yes you want to say it was really cold
yes i was in an accident yes uh all this
other stuff yes and then you get to that
part you can't do that first but then
explain yeah no you're right you're
right but it's out there for all time on
the internet it's it's out there forever
you're and you're wondering how how did
this man make kids with that
[Laughter]